there's just so much to learn from
amazon and this little company in
seattle
had become a trillion dollar empire and
bezos the wealthiest person in the world
would you say bezos's number one nemesis
right now is
elon musk elon came in with spacex and
kind of just went much faster
and got the government to pay for a lot
of his projects and so
jeff has been uniquely in space kind of
struggling to catch up he's not used to
being the second at anything
why does bezos like to be more private
rather than public maybe the
down is dangerous look it's personality
he's not like a steve jobs or an elon
musk where he can whip up his followers
into a frenzy of fandom on style wise
what would that be with bezos maybe a
lack of empathy
the longer term well-being of employees
and that sounds
brutal and it is you know and i think
we've seen some of the impact of that
from the fulfillment centers how tough
that environment is and how amazon tends
to churn through employees
and bezos is the architect of that
system you know it almost seems like
she's okay with a lot of things
but he is not okay with the unionization
of amazon why is that
let me put it this way the amazon
website is 24 7. so they're hiring and
they're firing and they're working
around the clock
there's a backlog they're shifting
employees to different jobs
and all those things patrick that i just
described are things that you know a
union
is going to collectively bargain against
you know we've seen again and again
around the world amazon walking away
from from facilities when the discussion
turns to unions
[Music]
so if you want to find out about the 180
billion dollar man today maybe 200 by
the time you watch it but the 180
billion dollar man jeff bezos
learn more about him there is no one
that's written and researched
him more than my guest today bradstone
who
is a senior executive editor for global
technology at bloomberg news and he
oversees
a team of 65 reporters and editors that
cover high-tech companies startups cyber
security and internet trends
around the world he wrote a book in 2013
called the everything store about amazon
which became the goldman sachs business
book of the year award that's pretty big
deal to get
didn't please mackenzie scott at the
time mckenzie
bezos at the time when the book came out
but uh raving reviews we read it
ourselves translated in 35 different
languages
and after writing a book about bezos
eight years later he writes another book
called
amazon unbound jeff bezos and the
invention
of a global empire which just came out
last week with that being said brad
thank you
so much for being a guest on
valuetainment hi patrick
thanks for having me yes so so is this
true that you are a twin and you're a
father of twins is that true or
that is true i like to say that we are
reproducing at an exponential rate
that's impressive man i got to tell you
they they say it skips a generation but
apparently they didn't skip yours
my family is littered with them oh so
your family is little with them yeah
cousins and and extended family yeah oh
you're crazy maybe there is a secret
sauce in your family we don't know about
maybe your next book needs to be how to
produce twins we don't know maybe
there's an audience for that anyways
let's get right into it so brad
out of everybody you can study out of
everybody can go out there and you know
research and you know do what you do
about
why did you pick jeff bezos boy i mean
early on it was it was almost
circumstance patrick i
i was writing about silicon valley for
the new york times and then bloomberg
and you know there were books about
google and apple and facebook and
um you know amazon seemed a little bit
of the the cipher
in the tech community up there in
seattle private uh fiercely secretive
and so the everything store was born out
of you know opportunism
he you know i wanted to write a company
i about and a person who i thought was
interesting
and of course then amazon became very
interesting and the book kind of hit at
a moment
where uh the book industry in the larger
world was grappling with amazon's power
and then you know five six years passed
and the story had changed
and and this little company in seattle
had become a trillion dollar
empire and bezos the wealthiest person
in the world and so i sort of realized
my
first effort needed a sequel a second
chapter and
and then in some ways as i was working
on the book the story just kept getting
more interesting
so so first time you interviewed it's
interesting when you're saying that
because at first you're like why would
he write a book about it and you and i
were talking offline it's a complete
different
animal today was a 120 billion dollar
company i believe in 2012 when you were
writing the book that 150 000 employees
give or take today they're
1.625 trillion auto company 1.2 million
employees
and he's all over the place he's bought
a lot of different things about to buy a
lot of other companies maybe we'll talk
about
the possibility of them buying uh mgm
but
you know the first book i feel like uh
uh
in a part of the book you write the fact
that you had a chance to interview him
for the first book then when you came
out he wasn't too happy about it because
of a part of the story
can you tell us what the evolution is
from the first book to the second book
right well i mean first of all you know
the the books are similar in one respect
you know there's just so much to learn
from amazon it is
it is almost the you know the example of
modern business and the
opportunity of disruption um and so you
know
both i think both books are are full of
revelations and lessons for students of
business so let's
let's just posit that in terms of the
company's
cooperation there it was actually very
similar maybe even a little bit better
this time in terms of
you know the company emerging from a
shell allowing me to interview senior
executives
um bezos himself was very guarded on the
first book he
he he sort of like listened to my pitch
and then he said he didn't want to
cooperate
as you mentioned uh patrick the book
came out he didn't like it for a number
of reasons including the depiction of
its
corporate culture is pretty you know
tough uh and of course i
you know feel like that's sort of been
proven out amply by time and various
testimony from employees
and then there was a personal aspect to
it which i think you're referring to
which is
i ended up tracking down his biological
father long-lost
biological father in the first book and
and that
sort of hit a little bit too close to
home you mentioned the negative review
from uh his wife at the time mckenzie
and then years passed and you know when
i came to him for this book
they they you know he and and emailed
him directly
you know he decided they decided to
cooperate he he didn't give me an
interview for this book but you know i
would point to the fact that over the
past few years you know bezos has been a
scarce
entity on the on the public stage at
least i mean he's obviously been out
there but in terms of interviews and
reflections
and grappling with the tough questions
around amazon
he just doesn't tend to do that a lot so
that that prompts two questions right
there that
that i'll go to one of them then the
other one the first one is the
father that uh you know chasing him down
and then
you know wanting to speak with the
biological father what was that
experience like for you when you spoke
did you see a resemblance did was he
shocked i can't believe my son is doing
this what did you notice when he spoke
to
his father yeah well i mean
i'll i'll just say you know back then i
was sort of curious well what makes
what are the ingredients you know that
go into such a
unique and driven entrepreneur
entrepreneur
and business figure and you know and
that is
everything from his mentors to his early
jobs and of course to his upbringing
and you know patrick he went to his high
school years and largely grew up there
in south florida
and you know talked to friends and and
um family members
he allowed me to talk to his parents his
mother and his father who's actually
really a stepfather and and one of the
questions that i was considering as i
pursued it is
you know well okay so where was the
biological father
and had that created any kind of an
absence in his life that contributed to
his remarkable drive
so you know tracked down the father who
was running a bike shop in
in arizona and it turned out that the
guy hadn't known
that his son had become jeff bezos and
that ended up just being a sort of
remarkable story
and a little bit of a wistful story and
tied back into the amazon story because
bezos had always run the company
with this principle of never having any
regrets and here i had tracked down the
father figure
who had been important in his very early
life then had left the family and had a
lot of regrets
so in that way it tied a bow around one
aspect to that story
yeah he talks about regret uh
minimization i think that's the word he
uses i think it's
what you use in a book the first one but
going back with uh his father
are you saying like his father didn't
know
that jeff was his son like you had to
find out oh so you so you had to find
out through his mom
who is his biological father and okay
walking through that part yeah yeah no
let me clarify no he he knew he had a
son in high school
okay the couple was uh in high school he
knew at his son they were married
he was in their lives for for two or
three years after that
and then they they got divorced and he
left
and he had lost track of the family and
didn't know what had happened to the son
that he had as a kid
and didn't know if he was alive or not
and then
ultimately when i knocked on his door in
didn't know that this wealthy
public-facing famous businessman was
that kid
that baby he literally had no idea
no idea no
after the meeting with you and him did
he reach out to jeff edol did they have
any kind of uh
interactions or conference meetings or
yeah he he tried to reach out and and
bezos
uh wrote him a note and then he and then
he passed away
about a year later i think so they never
met they never met up
as far as i know okay as far as you know
you know it's interesting
and i'm curious to know what you're
saying maybe you don't have an opinion
on this maybe you do
do you notice a correlation between
uh individuals who you know there are
people that become millionaires
there are people that become
billionaires i mean you know you can
come up with a good idea become a
billionaire
but there are a few people that for
whatever
flip and reason they cannot stop
they can't even help themselves it's
this energy like
when is it going to be enough for you
when like and then you go back and you
study
elon musk with the relationship with his
father you'll know you know all this
stuff and then you know steve jobs mom
you know hey how do you give me up and
you know bezos father do you think there
is a correlation with
one of the parents almost
not seeing like they're gonna amount to
anything how dare you leave me that i'm
gonna prove a point the rest of my life
for you to say
you weren't there do you kind of see
something like that that's why i was
curious about that but let's put it this
way
uh let's not advise that an ingredient
to good parenting or raising a motivated
child is to leave
is to depart their life that's prob but
and yet um
i that you know yeah i i think so in
some way
um you know and obviously every every
kid abandoned by a parent is
you know not going to be a high achiever
in fact probably the opposite is true
and yet in some of those
cases and you know we can look to bill
clinton or barack obama
you know when the parental figure was
missing it it seemed to have been at
least one ingredient
in a remarkable ambition and and level
of achievement
and yeah that's what i was you know i'm
not a psychologist or
you know so i don't i don't really know
but certainly that's why i went down
that path
and you know and it's an open question
you know
whether that was sort of fair game right
and i don't you know and even after all
all these years i mean i'll defend it
but i think it's a you know it's a good
question you know like probing into the
private life in the early life of uh of
a business figure
i mean i would say that bezos has now
had has made an impact on this
on this world to such an extent that um
you know
understanding uh from whence he came and
that
elixir you know that fueled him is is is
interesting
i think that's an understatement when
you think about you know the impact he's
made in the world and i don't think he's
stopping anytime soon
even though he gave it up to andy jazzy
from aws which by the way in an
interview with google seven years ago
when they asked you who do you think
would replace him you actually brought
up andy's name that could potentially
one day because
the guys at the top are loyal to him yes
they may have a high turnover ratio and
middle management but the guys at the
top
enjoy working with them based on the
culture that they have there tyler perry
i don't know if you know who tyler perry
is you may know
of course he's a a very big name he said
one time that he had a fallen out with
his dad i believe
and he told us that how much do i have
to spend for you to never call me ever
again if i buy you a house if i buy you
a car if i spend money
because he wanted to say you were not
there during the years i'm gonna
i'm gonna let you know right now you
want money i'll get this i'll get this
i'll get that because i want to go out
there
but there almost seems like there's a
driver that i thought maybe a little bit
more
uh to go into be very interesting if a
psychologist or psychiatrist and you
actually worked on a project together
to see how much deeper that can get the
other part you said is
the fact that uh when you wanted to go
interview him he kind of like no i let
my executives talk to you but not myself
and you said he's more on the private
side he doesn't like to you know
go and you know talk about those tough
conversations
you know elon musk on the opposite end
he's like
total opposite he'll tweet you know
he'll go
smoke weed with joe he'll go you know
hey
69 000 for the tesla 420
a share we're gonna go buy it back he's
a troll master
chess master game all this stuff that he
does
why does bezos like to be more private
rather than public is it a personality
thing or is it just kind of a
you know he sees way too much risk and
being in a public eye
yeah it's a great question i mean elon i
mean their styles are so different
elon has you know everything that you
described but also he's
you know we can admit maybe that he's
undisciplined uh the tweets are
you know as likely to get him into
trouble either regulatory or
or legal as whip as fans and into a
frenzy
um it's his it's a style it's been
unmistakably effective he can do it in
part because his ventures are
really inspirational tesla and um and
spacex
you know bezos maybe you know yes
there's a personal personality
difference he's so disciplined
and careful the stories that he tells in
interviews are like polished little
stones that he's
used and deployed over the years i've
heard them all i could probably give the
speech myself
you know at the same time he is uh the
ceo the founder of a company that evokes
much more complicated feelings than
people
you know uh um
and that's you know that's um rightly or
not um
but it's a retailer it's it's
competition is
sympathetic small and pop mom and pop
businesses
um it's sort of like in some respects
walmart you know a juggernaut
from afar that reaches into communities
it employs tons of people in everyone's
local community
it's got complicated kind of tax release
schemes
and it's a lightning rod it is it is
it's occupied that place in the public
imagination right now where people
both depend on it and in the same breath
after they're clicking the buy now
button they're criticizing it right i
mean
and so maybe he has to be more careful
maybe to sit down
and make himself available like elon
does is
in some respects dangerous because he's
going to be asked about
taxes and relationship with the workers
and
competition so i don't i don't know but
he is just more disciplined and careful
and he look it's personality he can't he
he he
he can't he's not like a steve jobs or
an elon musk where he can whip up his
followers into
you know a frenzy a fandom it's just
he's a he's kind of still a geek
patrick when it gets down to it a nerd
so
so would you categorize i mean that's a
good way of putting it would you say
musk jobs gates zuck
you know uh or bezos would you kind of
say the personalities where
gates is a little bit more he's been in
the public eye more lately you know
vaccine all this other stuff here's what
we need to do challenges we're facing
but would you kind of put it more on the
gates and zuck side than the elan and
job site
maybe that's true i mean in some ways i
think he tries to be up here
hovering above it you know he's so
strategic
in in what he says and how he talks and
where he does it
in some ways it's when he talks when he
writes a letter to shareholders
when he gives an interview with a fellow
billionaire on a stage somewhere
or when he talks about blue origin a
space company it's tactical
he's trying to deliver a message you
know he's he's you know
one of the things is he's just
incredibly strategic with his time
and so partly it might be that but when
he does talk there's always a goal
and a you know an endgame so i don't
know that he's really even that
consumed with his public image um i mean
he certainly does care about it because
you see him responding to criticism in
his writing and
and his and the speeches he does give
but um i think he just tries to sort of
hover above it
and no longer really cares perhaps and
with a 180 billion dollar fortune maybe
he doesn't have to
uh you know cares that much about
getting people to really understand him
i i think he cares though i think he
cares because he does
yeah because you know he responded to
trump and his guy told him not to do it
and you were kind of talking about it
yourself hey
just let it go jake you know all that
stuff that was gonna let it go
no he responds and they had this little
battle going on back and forth
i asked because you know uh
it's an old school style he has like
this whole thing about being in the
public eye is more new school it's not
old school social media has almost
forced a lot of ceos to be in a public
eye generally
you know powerful business people were
like listen
just you know i don't want to do a lot
of interviews you know your publicist
would say don't talk to anybody what if
you say the wrong thing
where today it's more like let me go
handle let me respond back on twitter
let me go do this we have more access so
it does show a lot of discipline to him
internally you know as you did the
interview from the first book to the
second one
obviously on the second one you're
saying you didn't meet with him but he
did allow you to go on interview a lot
of his executive which is great
did you ever read the book accidental
millionaire that was written in the 80s
i want to say uh
it was a book written in the 80s about
jobs and these were former employees
that left you know the book accidental
billionaire about zuck
prior to accidental billionaire there
was a book called accidental millionaire
and it was written when you read the
book you could tell
it was written by a former employee who
hated
jobs i mean couldn't stand jobs and in
many documentaries when they interview
people that worked with jobs at his peak
you know you talk about bully which
we'll get to
chapter three here in a minute but they
say you know
uh uh how he was and how he would you
know flip out and this and that
when you were doing interviews from
people recently
not oh not 2013 i'm talking about
recently
and interviewing former people as well
as exec
existing people what things have you
seen evolved in the last eight years
from 2012 to 2020 2021
in terms of the corporate culture or the
yeah in terms of like let's just say
2003 when you were talking to
disgruntled employees who left they
would say oh he saw this
maybe disgruntled employees that now
left are saying something different and
the people that are there who are happy
are saying something different like
bazel's has changed because of dot dot
yeah
well first of all you know yes there are
disgruntled employees
but you know it it's the preponderance
of of the
of the workers that i've interviewed
over the years you know have been
i think pretty sort of a clear-eyed
um you know and frank about
their contributions the the the pride
they took at the work but also
but also the some of the disadvantages
or the you know the leadership style
that
ultimately burned them out so it wasn't
it's not quite disgruntled it's
sometimes exhausted or
you know post traumatic stress disorder
from being lashed to a rocket ship
you know captained by a ceo who just
never stopped
and in the early years they described
this
leadership style that was brusque and
demanding and sometimes demeaning and
intimidating
and in the first book the everything
store i tell all sorts of stories of
bezos saying
remarkable things you know like why are
you wasting my life
and then and amazon unbound that
leadership style has matured somewhat
um you know he he he doesn't you know he
bottles that
up uh and you know but he still has
incredibly high standards
and he'll walk out of a room if he feels
like employees haven't solved the
problem
or aren't betting big enough or thinking
big enough or don't have an ingenious
solution to something
i tell the story in amazon unbound of
alexa
and the creation of alexa which she
sponsored and got into the details of it
and it's really
you know this lesson for i think anybody
in business of you know
how just having the idea isn't enough
but you have to as a ceo sort of use
your leadership magic to sponsor it
to get into the details to understand
the technical specifications
and then to allow your employees as one
says
quarter in the book is to be unbound you
know to not limit themselves in terms of
how they're thinking or investing the
the big
question with alexa was how they they
were going to test it
and ultimately before launch ultimately
they bring it out into the world
uh in disguise and they rent apartments
and houses and shroud the thing with the
acoustic fabric
and get contractors to go through
reciting scripts and that's the only
reason why i got smart enough to launch
and that was bezos basically pushing his
people so yeah i think the quality
the the tenor of the testimony about the
culture has changed
but in some ways it's just as difficult
it's just his leadership style softened
a little bit
so okay his leadership starts off on a
little bit but it's still so
so do you notice what do you notice with
the guys that can stay with them long
term because
when you're working with a hard charging
guy listen it's got to be very annoying
it's not going to be something you look
for you either like it and you're almost
just as screwed up as the other person
is that you're driven by it
or you're just like i can tolerate this
for five years i don't know if i can do
this 10 years
or 20 years i'm going to use this as a
resume then i'm going to go work at
netflix i'm going to go work out
whatever right
but those you notice that can last with
bazels long term
what do they have in common
they tend to think like him i think they
buy into the
the leadership style and the culture
um they are um you know they're
they're independent thinkers um they're
they're creative
you know bezos had you know jeff wilkie
for a long time he he retired last year
he was the head of the consumer business
and then andy jassy who's taking over
i mean they both were really you know
like proteges
in a way and made big contributions on
both sides of the business
but i think actually one factor patrick
is that bezos just trusted them and then
gave them a lot of
leeway and autonomy and you know
he bezos focuses on the new things and
wilkie ran the retail business and jassy
ran
the the cloud business and and then
bezos would sort of show up
every so often to you know to push them
and sometimes to undermine them or
make them you know rethink elements of
their business and so
you know i think i think the tolerance
for that style was was sort of key
because obviously you know if you're if
you've created a you know multi-billion
dollar business
and then the boss is showing up i think
to blow blow you up every once in a
while that takes a little bit of
patience and self-awareness
and you have to have a lot of respect
for the boss as well so
i think that's that's that's another key
element they they've they all had they
all seem to you know be members of the
bezos admiration club
and of course you have to be if you're
going to be in there for the long haul
and put up with the challenges of
of that culture you know it's because
you're buying in not just to the style
but to the guy
and the belief that you know he's a
visionary and he's right about a lot of
things
he's the prophet i mean he's he's a true
prophet visionary you know since
and what makes them you know i guess
i'll ask this question before we go to
the next topic is
on on style wise you know there are
leaders who are very good with
messaging they have a vision they want
to go out there and do this there are
those who are
maybe not very good at expressing their
message to you but they're very
disciplined so they come in hey where's
this it's time hey 30 minutes is 30
minutes i didn't say 31 minutes
so they're very much respecting their
time of their time there are those who
are
great sales people there are those who
are great developers a product they're
innovative they're creating like a jobs
right there are those that are actually
very good with numbers like they know
how to go raise the money and hey we'll
go get this and
they'll speak the balance sheet language
better than others they're almost like a
cfo but they're not
and then there are some that just sheer
drive
competition which one would you say base
if you were to say
his number one not pat he's all of that
i get that
but i want to know like i know but you
know like
i'm talking about the one thing above it
all
what would that be with baseballs
okay um so we're going to posit that
most of the boxes are checked sure yeah
of course you know he's
but you know i'm going to say actually
that there's a little bit
just to round it out um a little bit of
a what i would call
maybe a lack of empathy or you know
a willingness to disregard uh
feelings um the need to drive to
consensus
yeah um you know the longer-term
well-being of
employees and that's you know it sounds
brutal and it
and it is you know and i think we've
seen some of the impact of that
from the fulfillment centers how tough
that environment is and how amazon tends
to churn through employees
and bezos is the architect of that
system and
he doesn't care and maybe that is the
you know the the ingredient uh par part
of it of his success and the thing that
also
is not to be emulated or you know in
most environments we would want to think
carefully about emulating it
um you know this is this is part of the
reason why it's a it's a difficult
culture
and why the rate of turnover is high and
why he doesn't seem to care he sits on
top of this
massive expanding empire because in some
ways you know that he's focused on
the construction of a business that
serves customers and the feelings of
everyone who is
in the middle making that machinery work
doesn't really matter
and and and i don't know maybe that's it
because there are plenty of inventors
and innovators and there's
plenty of business architects and yet he
has constructed
a business on a scale that's been almost
unknown to man
and it's because he never stops and
doesn't slow down it doesn't seem to
concern himself
with the things that might you know give
you or i a little pause
yeah that that that that's what i
figured and it's leading me to the next
subject here
uh let me write my next question here uh
so so
you know lack of empathy okay um
it's almost like not feeling guilty for
what others have to do to get to work
you do it you do it you don't i don't
care it's your fault it's not my fault
like you have to do the work i don't
feel guilty for your lack of
effort or lack of desire to want to
learn and prove i get that that's you
you got to own that i don't know that
okay
elon musk is on snl okay and i'm sure
you saw when he was on snl right and he
got up and you know
maybe something you know bezos would
never do but elon gets up there and he's
on snl he says
i'm actually making history tonight as a
first person with asperger's to host snl
or at least the first to admit to it
so i won't make a lot of eye contact
with the castaner but um but already i'm
pretty good at
running human in emulation mode right he
touches on this
asperger's things and back in the days
they would write about gates with this
you know hey he has that and it was a
rumor underline that people would talk
about that
you know he would lash out and walk out
of worthy you don't feel bad for anybody
just hurt this guy's feelings
you know do you do you and i know you
don't talk about this you've not talked
about in the first book nor the second
book
is there is there an element of that
where
it gives you the advantage because
rejection you're like you don't even
know what rejection feels like because
you don't have emotions for it do you
kind of see
a strength and a correlation with that
and succeeding at this level
you know that's interesting and and uh
it's a really good question
and yes it's definitely one that i've
thought about and of course resisted
making any medical diagnosis because
i don't know um uh but you know to look
at it
sort of you know to take a step back
there is a remarkable ability
that bezos has to fail uh in public
you know the the fire phone is a great
example that smartphone that bombed i
tell that story and
and great story about it yeah very good
story yeah um
you know other efforts um when when he
battled with the national enquirer over
his personal relationship
you know and and posted that that
article on medium
um you know that basically risked
embarrassment and you know did something
that probably most of us
you know wouldn't wouldn't consider
doing and and you know moved on and
actually was quite effective
the risking of embarrassment is another
aspect of this
you know of this ability to not you know
not
seem seemingly to care that much about
public embarrassment
yeah there's there's a little bit of a
shield you know to
some of the negative uh effects of
growth and
fame and that he has and it's been
remarkable
armor i think for him so yes i think
it's definitely if
if you know if he is like elon somewhere
there on the spectrum and we you know we
don't know and
by the way i've met elon and um i never
thought that that was true
so i thought that was surprising that he
would say that about himself
uh but in any event yeah i mean it's
it's clearly can be effective in in some
aspects of business building
are you saying you met ilan because ilan
actually has a personality and he's
loose and
you know is that why you're saying why
you never thought you would have that
yeah
yes yeah yeah because even when you see
that you like even on snl he looked like
he was having a he was like a little kid
in a candy store
you know i think the biggest thing was
did you watch tiger woods documentary
that came out
i don't know if you uh i haven't yet i'm
looking forward to it i highly recommend
i just watch it a few weeks so it's not
like i watch it when it first came out
people kept telling me you got to watch
i'm like i'll watch it it's because you
know
last dance was so great what the hell is
going to reach last dance right
but when you watch it there is a scene
that
you know there's a lot of scenes that
stuck out to me but there was one scene
where his girlfriend from high school
they had videos of tiger
at her house and at this time tiger's a
phenom the world already knows who he is
they already know he's gonna be a star
so it's not like he's not
known but there's this part about tiger
just being
childlike and he was just letting loose
and then when his dad was around
yes i plan on winning 19. i feel like
will be the greatest
so it was like a robotic but behind
closed doors it was just like
loose thing i think what we're starting
to see with elon is
elon's just finally accepted the fact
that he's this you know big kid stuck in
a brilliant genius
guy's body and he's okay being himself i
think
elon's probably reached a level of
comfort in himself
more than some of these other guys have
and i think the world's enjoyment is
brilliance yeah i may be wrong who knows
but that's what i noticed with them
if you don't mind sharing that story
with uh the the phone because
that's a great uh uh management uh uh
uh a tip to give to other leaders on how
to deal with some of their folks who
go through massive failures i think it's
a great story if you don't mind sharing
with the audience
sure and and and let's uh recognize that
amazon is in a
unique position to fail right it uh you
know has this engine of
cash growth in the retail business and
the cloud business so bezos believes he
can try a lot of different things
and at the time that he's just stating
alexa he you know has this idea for a
phone he wants to enter
you know this this category of of uh of
device that's growing so quickly with
the iphone and samsung devices back in
and you know he he has a notion for a
phone with a three-dimensional screen
that'll give you kind of a 3d image with
all these front-facing cameras
and you can use the phone to scan any
product and i'll give you a price and
show you how to build it
and he he whips up the project inside
the company
like alexa he kind of manages it closely
the employees on it
really don't get the vision they think
that amazon should be offering
a low price consistent with its image
but he wants something very distinctive
and they even buy the employees buy dog
tags that say disagree and commit which
is a
leadership principle inside amazon but a
kind of sly way of saying that they
didn't really buy into it
and you know the thing takes forever
suddenly the parts are outdated
they have to restart the project inside
the company launches in in 2014
uh it bombs reviews are terrible
customers don't buy it
and bazel says okay fine doesn't punish
his executives
doesn't necessarily embrace the blame
publicly because it was his idea
but he moves on quickly and three months
later they they announce alexa
so in some ways the i think the lesson
is uh
trying a lot of different things
embracing failure not uh
you know not punishing the organization
or your employees when you when
when you fail not losing a lot of time
to go
recognize the failure take the right off
get past it
um you know and and then the fact that
you know if even if you fail as long as
you're trying
you know five other things and one of
them hits you're going to come out ahead
which is what happened with amazon and
alexa
that that's that's a good story for him
you know obviously it's his idea that
phil but a guy the vp
that had the project at least he told
him i don't want you to what was the
line i don't want you to think about it
for a minute
promise me you won't think about it for
a minute and you'll move on so it shows
a different side of his
but you know there's a story about you
chasing down the voice actress of alexa
in boulder colorado
and she told you that she cannot
interview with you
what was the re is that an nda she has
that she can't talk to what was it can
you tell us about that
sure well let me set the stage really
quickly uh when i'm coming into this
book
amazon unbound i'm thinking well what
what what are the
what are the secrets to unlock here and
there were a number of them
and but one of them was whose voice was
emanating from this device in my kitchen
we had known that there was a voice
actress behind siri so i figured the
same thing was true for alexa
and you know and i've got all sorts of
bits about the creation of alexa the
first whiteboard drawing that bezos drew
on in his conference room of the device
in 2011
but that voice was interesting and i
thought you know can i find her identity
you know did some digging some detective
work and yeah found a voice actress
named nina raleigh
in boulder colorado and right when i
called her she really said she couldn't
talk
which i figured was the case um you know
yes and an
nda amazon i think probably prefers
the people to think of the voice alexa
as a kind of voice of god
emanating you know from amazon's own
computer servers
but in fact there's a voice actress
who's recording a lot of audio in her
home studio probably
and and those sentences and and phrases
and paragraphs she utters
those are the words and the phrases are
all split up
you know fed into into a voice
recognition system
and then you know put back together in
you know incoherent
uh sometimes coherent let's say phrases
to respond to user queries
so that was a fun little detail in the
book yeah that's definitely
interesting because i mean she's more
famous than she
nobody knows what she looks like i guess
if you google you know what she looks
like but
to most people she may be one of the
most famous people in the world at least
her voice well
i i would say maybe the most famous
voice in in history i would have to say
yeah what could compete with that but um
you know and she's been in the last four
or five super bowls too without without
recognition
it's crazy i mean the only the voice
that i think is very recky maybe it's a
good voice morgan freeman but as far as
famous
it would probably have to be hers you
know uh when when you think about
bezos the guy's extremely strategic you
talk about him being a you know master
chess you know plays chess with the game
i don't is he even a chess player does
he play chess or that's not his game
no i believe he i believe he does i
recall him telling stories about playing
chess with his grandfather growing up
okay got it so that's part of it as well
but in the world of business the guy
knows what moves to make it seems like
he's 15 moves ahead he knows his next
five moves
all the time and when you look at the
companies he buys he bought whole foods
you're like
what whole food you know you're like
okay
oh i got great brilliant he buys twitch
you know he buys
you know washington post why would you
buy washington post i got it to control
the narrative a little bit of media if
they're going to come after you got a
big platform
you got a good place all this stuff
you're looking at what he buys
prime all these things that he goes
through that he built you know zap
zappos there's always a motive behind
where he's going
himself what's what's the motive behind
his hit interest with mgm obviously we
don't know if the deal is going to get
done or not
but what is his motive behind the uh
what do you think is the motive behind
wanting to buy mgm
right well uh about a decade ago
let's start let's start here uh amazon
is the everything store
they want all their shelves full
infinite selection
and early on dvds um home movies were
one shelf of the everything store
you know and and that business starts to
decline uh the sale of physical dvds is
going away so what what does amazon do
it starts a video on demand store
you can buy movies and stream and and
download them
and then netflix comes along with a
subscription service
you know pay a certain amount per per
month and and watch anything you want
so amazon copies that bezos integrates
it into prime
it's free for prime members then amazon
and netflix are dueling
uh to license shows like friends or
seinfeld it's very expensive it's
you know hbo and showtime in the 80s and
what they realize is it's less expensive
more strategic to just make those shows
and movies themselves
so netflix and amazon get into the
production of original
tv shows and movies that's the battle
that we've seen now over many years
and mgm is you know a huge catalog of
the james bond movies the survivor tv
show
and uh the rocky movies the creed movies
amazon can plug into its vast catalog
of prime video that's a subscription
service they also have something called
imdb
tv which is a free streaming service
supported by ads
so in some ways mgm is you know a shot
of steroids into its in the into this
catalog
of content that could tie people closer
to the prime service
and when they're prime members or
they're using imdb tv
you know they're better amazon customers
they're buying more they're
buying kindles and alexas that's that's
essentially it
um it's this foot race that amazon has
engaged in with all these other
companies disney
apple um now hbo owned by time warner
being joined with discovery uh and
netflix and on and on
to own entertainment in the 21st century
got it so almost like how
disney disconnected themselves from you
know netflix and they went and created
their own
ott and it blew up i think it's the
fastest growing in the world
out of all the otts so he's thinking
about taking the mgm catalog and adding
it to amazon
you know uh what is it called amazon
their own hulu their own ott
there's a name yeah so prime video
and then imdb tv and then you know and
then also the original you know
mgm is a as a movie studio and and it's
got some interesting stuff coming out um
it has the creed franchise and amazon is
in business you know with
um michael jordan the the actor um
and and so there's lots of avenues there
for amazon
to turbo charge it's it's video
offerings if it buys a conventional
studio yeah
it almost seems like he sits there and
he says oh
who can we go up against let's go
against netflix yeah that's cool uh
let's go let what we already took out
borders let's do barnes
how about walmart you know how about uh
well he just seeds no ground
right it's it's this belief that the
company that the you know that
it needs it should be everywhere where
the internet is offering opportunity
so he failed on the phone side which
means let's go up against apple and uh
you know android for instance okay
samsung he failed there fine do you
think he has anything
said in uh that he may want to go up
against the social media world i'm
talking facebook twitter
any of those guys it's re that's really
interesting patrick because early on
i i found out that at one point he
actually had some of the earliest social
media patents um and didn't do much with
them
and um you know i think that's one area
of
you know with which they they haven't
been that aggressive
um twitch is maybe the sort of explicit
you know
anomaly there but but that's a little
bit more of a youtube competitor yeah it
is
and tied closely to video games um
they've they have a
social network for books called
goodreads but they haven't done much
with it
so yeah that's one area where maybe
maybe
uh you know uniquely they haven't shown
much ambition
yeah i'd be curious to know because uh
you know
long-term wise that's the one area where
you almost
need to have some control if you want to
have a so but we saw google try to do
google plus and it didn't work out maybe
he saw that as a playbook of well it's
not that easy to do
let's go different i don't know so and
by the way i mean maybe that's been
smart i mean they've grown an
advertising business without those
assets
and the social networks are in the
middle of a political storm that seems
unending now and around free speech and
political expression and
amazon plenty of controversy and
regulatory attention but
it's managed to skate past that per
particular issue
that's a that's a very good point that's
a very good point you always see jack
dorsey zuck all those guys
you know always being grilled and i
don't know if he likes being grilled so
let's talk about him against aoc what
happened when they were trying to go to
new york and
hey we're going to bring a 125 000 jobs
at an average of a 25 000 jobs at an
average of 150 000
a year salary cuomo wanted it but de
blasio
aoc they kind of pushed him out we don't
want you to come here you're going to
increase rent you're going to do that
and he's kind of like wait a minute what
are we talking about here i'm just
bringing you good jobs
how did he handle that and what caused
him to finally say
screw it we're going to go a different
direction they didn't handle it very
well
they were fleeing a political storm in
seattle where
the amazon had started to become blamed
for the problems of growth like
gentrification and homelessness and
rising home rates
and that precipitated the hq2 search
that and the fact that they were kind of
running out of space in seattle
and you know they whipped up the country
in a frenzy of competition for
for hq2 folks probably remember that 238
cities applied
you know they were talking about things
like the low cost of construction they
were looking for
affordable home prices uh the size of
tax incentives
good transportation networks and then
they pick new york in washington dc and
so right off the bat
you know the world's kind of shocked
because that is not what they set out to
do
and where they it's where they ended the
most expensive
exactly um and and look and and i tell
the story in the book i've got the
internal memos
the decision process was largely driven
by by the personal preferences of bezos
and the leadership team
so they go in there they get de blasio
and cuomo to agree on on the amazon
package in long island city
but the city council isn't informed and
and the dynamics of
you know political dynamics in new york
are such that you know whatever de
blasio wants
is you know the council is going to kind
of reject aoc had just been elected
and i think the surprise for amazon was
that the same political dynamics
you know that were hurting them in
seattle were there in new york
you know the big tech companies the tech
lash the fear of gentrification
um you know so the political backlash
starts
bezos is into helicopters at the time so
he asked for a helipad in the in the
queen's headquarters
and uh you know the new york post puts
it on the front page
and they're off to the races and and
ultimately you know they were sort of
unprepared for the backlash they didn't
really get their message out
and then the whole thing kind of
crystallizes on the issue of unions
and whether amazon would allow its
workers to unionize and bezos has always
thought that from the very beginning he
sees it as
kryptonite for the company and so when
you know what i concluded was that when
talks went to unionization
and they saw the political landscape was
the same as it was in seattle
it just wasn't worth it for them and
they they pulled out they grew instead
in manhattan and then in
in washington dc or in northern virginia
crystal city
you know it almost seems like he's okay
with taxes increasing he's okay with
raising minimum wage he's okay with a
lot of things
but he is not okay with the union uh
union unionization of amazon why is that
right well um you know
what they'll say and then we'll get to
the real reason is that they don't want
an intermediary between them and their
employees
but let me put it this way you know the
the amazon website is 24
7. you can buy in the middle of the
night right you can buy on a holiday you
can buy on a sunday
and what that means is that the company
really has to get as close as possible
to a 24 7 operating cycle
and to go scale up in during the
holidays or when
if a pandemic breaks out and someone's
suddenly buying
or if there's a sudden surge in interest
for a particular piece of merchandise
and then they scale down afterwards so
they're hiring and they're firing and
they're working around the clock
and they're suddenly you know if there's
a backlog they're shifting employees to
different jobs
um and all those things patrick that i
just described are things that
you know a union that's going to you
know very quite naturally want to
instill some order on their workers
lives
and create some employment security it's
going to collectively bargain against
and so i think amazon's viewed unions as
a
as an impediment to their ability to
push employees
to be flexible and to churn through
workers in the fulfillment centers as
the needs of the company change
that's probably the most charitable way
to put it um
you know but um you know we've seen
again and again
around the world amazon walking away
from from facilities when the discussion
turns to unions
yeah you see like even what was going on
with georgia he's like
right the day before they announced that
uh uh you know they were about to
announce that hey the voting all that
stuff that was going to take place the
day before
he goes up and says i think we should
raise taxes and i think we should
you know p the rich people should pay
more taxes and then the next day the
union topic just kind of went away
it almost seemed like behind closed
doors there was a negotiation saying if
you
say something about raising taxes will
make atlanta go away or georgia go when
it kind of did
uh with the union topic but let's go to
a different topic so everybody has
a an arch nemesis and some of them
change
some of them change from your 20s to
your 30s to your 40s and
you kind of graduate from it right every
time you go like let's just say when
michael's coming up maybe it was magic
then it became let's just say
isaiah you know then it became you know
somebody and barkley some of these guys
that you go through
would you say you know bezos's number
one
nemesis right now is a guy named elon
musk
well um yeah i mean it was donald trump
uh for many years uh they they famously
went at it and you know i tell some of
that story in the book
uh right now i i think maybe that's
right patrick um
bezos has this company blue origin it's
a space company it's older than spacex
but he made some choices early on to
constrain his investment to go slow keep
the head count small
and to move a step-by-step sub-orbital
space
then orbital then the moon and
elon came in with spacex and kind of you
know just went much faster and got the
government to pay for a lot of his
projects and so
jeff has been you know uniquely in space
kind of struggling to catch up he's not
used to being the second at anything
uh you know and and now he is and then
we see
amazon trying to launch a satellite
network to compete with starlink which
is a spacex effort
so i do think there's a spirited rivalry
there yeah for sure and i don't you know
i don't know that bezos look he is the
richest guy in the world and am
the creation of amazon probably dwarfs
you know the creation of other companies
at this
point in terms of just the impact and
the overall market cap so i don't know
how
really rivalrous he feels but certainly
in this respect
and the and and where we started the
conversation elon's ability
to whip uh his followers into fans while
bezos kind of
suffers the slings and arrows of
criticism for amazon's impact
on the economy yeah i'm sure he looks at
elon and sort of feels that there are
elements there that
uh you know he needs to work harder to
capture himself
does bezos kind of see him i know you
said it earlier where i said you know
it's
more like jobs musk you know uh zuck
gates bezos and he said no he kind of
sees himself here
is he is does he think he's michael
jordan does he think he's like brady
does he think he's
he's it does he walking thinking well
all these guys are trying to catch up to
me
or does he see himself as the underdog
man i gotta go be
better than what walmart build what this
guy did what rockefeller did what
is he like is there somebody he's
chasing does he have a ghost he's
chasing
like lebron's chasing the ghost yeah
like like that you know does he have
vanderbilt rockefeller is he going after
somebody like that
yeah i don't know i mean i can't speak
for him i don't i don't know
um he is a student to history right he
he's a voracious reader
there are elements of of the sam walton
philosophy and and autobiography that
he's woven into amazon
um look i mean i i
i'm gonna guess that i i don't think so
um but that he
he understands that part of the
uh legacy of some of the business
figures historical business figures you
mentioned
was their philanthropic contributions
and that he's got a lot of work to do
he's got a fortune that's about 200
billion dollars that'll probably grow
faster than he can give it away
and he's going to be measured based on
how productive and effective
he is doing that and we've seen um you
know
bill gates and and others make major
contributions but also sort of stumble
the the work of giving the money away
can be as difficult as the work of
accumulating the wealth
and so yeah he's got a lot of he's got a
lot of work to do yeah before
you know he's viewed as a you know
billionaire philanthropist who made a
positive contribution
and not just you know this operator who
managed to accumulate all this power
and you know the world feels very
complicated about bezos and
amazon right now so you know i don't
know that there's a person he's chasing
but there might be an ideal
um you know that he still has to get to
before he really retires last question
before we wrap up so
competition you know uh they say
70 of fortune 500 companies from 1960
were no longer around you know it's like
these companies are no longer on they
were
at the top everybody was like oh my gosh
and they're no longer around kmart was
god you know at one point and walmart
was trying to catch up after the 1962
and a half the super saving center year
where
walmart kmart target all came out five
years later
you know walmart has 250 uh kmart has
250 stores walmart has eight stores
kmart goes out of business walmart is
dominating today right
is amazon something that you see
yourself being around five years from
now
uh 50 years from now where this is going
to be so hard to beat these guys or
if there was a way where competition
could take these guys out
do you have any insight on how that
would be right
well five years from now is easy 50
years is harder
right now amazon is i like to say a
boulder rolling downhill gathering speed
the the fulfillment centers are getting
closer to major cities
the the delivery is getting faster um
the selection's getting larger as they
open up the marketplace to
sellers around the world and they've got
you know so many resources
not just the the profit of the company
but the the capital they're willing
they're able to raise
you know cheap prices from wall street
the future of amazon is more amazon
entering into more countries and more
products and becoming an entertainment
giant
in 50 years i mean one weakness of the
company
is that there's so much surface area
that there are these
pockets of opportunity for newcomers
shopify the canadian companies a good
example
of going right to brands who are
hesitant of kind of the chaos of amazon
to sell directly to customers so
i mean i think yeah i think amazon's
around in a couple of decades when bezos
sort of predicts that
you know the future could be cloudy he's
trying to motivate his employees
but this is a historic company i think
it's it's the company that's going to
define the current century
in good ways and bad and i think you
know if regulators and lawmakers want to
catch up to it
you know they need to understand it
which is one of the reasons i wrote the
book
and get into the mechanics and and
really look for
you know the true anti-competitive
behavior or behavior that needs to be
regulated
and it's not easy because this in some
ways it's not a monopoly it's in the
biggest
markets of the world retail and
enterprise software uh
and doesn't really command even a
majority of
the of the market activity so yeah i
think um
you know amazon will be around and if it
does get split up
there'll just be a lot of little baby
bezos is running around uh
gobbling up the marketplace so that's
not you know that
that's probably not going to give
competitors any comfort either which
means meaning they could go other places
and start other companies or you're
saying
within amazon eco eco well i was just
saying if
if if the government was going to break
up amazon
or amazon was going to break itself up
yeah um
it might not slow it down it just might
mean you know
some very highly valued independent
pieces that have the amazon culture
and the bezos operating style you know
and are just as aggressive and
competitive but
multiple entities instead of just one
yeah i mean you kind of saw that happen
with watson's and ibm where they try to
break them apart because
their only i think their only enemy
right now is going to be the government
we're saying hey
you're kind of becoming a monopoly and
and them getting in their way
uh and some of the guys may leave like
you know how back in the days if you
worked under jack welch you put that
onto your resume like i worked under
jack welch for five years really yeah
let's hire this guy as an executive and
bring him on board so some people may
use it as a
way to help them out with the rest of
their career brad it's been a pleasure
having you on man i really enjoy talking
to you folks if you're watching this
we're going to put the link to his book
amazon unbound below make sure you order
it
once again brad thanks for being on
valuetainment thanks patrick
so i'm curious what you took away from
this interview here about bezos amazon
culture how we work
his personality his dna the father story
fascinating stuff with uh
brad stone comment below i want to hear
from you also if you enjoyed this anyway
i've got two other ones i want you to
watch
one of them is with a deep dive that uh
tom ellsworth did on aws case study it's
extreme if you want to know more about
why aws
is crushing it and why andy jazzy became
the ceo of amazon click over to watch it
and if you want to find out about
storytelling and marketing why companies
like amazon end up becoming who they are
watch my interview with don miller on
how he breaks down the art of
storytelling and marketing take care
everybody bye-bye
you